it is time for a gentleman
and to become
rogues
let's go
you have no idea what i'm capable
of going to need a suit i might need a
shooting jacket
armed and ready
i never drink on duty
we are the first spy organization
[Music]
kingsman is it
and lady only theaters december 22nd
i'm offering you the opportunity to
become a kingsman agent
like a spy
of sorts
since 1849 kingsman taylors have clothed
the world's most powerful individuals by
1919 a great number of them had the
desire to preserve peace and protect
life
our founders realized that they could
channel wealth and influence for the
greater good
and so began an independent intelligence
agency operating at the highest level of
discretion
the kingsman agency
welcome to the club very clever
this movie
really is an origin story
this is the foundation of the kingsman
franchise manners
maker
man
spectacular day
oh yes very nice we see you in this film
the formation of the kingsmen get to the
lift the styles very matthew vaughn
matthew is an amazing storyteller and
he's written something quite powerful at
the center of this particular kingsman
film is the first world war
but it still has its recognizable
kingsman element
forget your manners oh
it's called a tailor shop it's got
complicated fight sequences
there's gadgetry of human action and
fantastical villains it's time to pour
fuel
we shall see
welcome
why is it that boys are always so messy
[Music]
you're going to need a suit
come on
[Music]
you